- I am a human, living,
walking, breathing mistake.
I have more umph.
I'm all about the messing up.
I like to koala on the eucalyptus tree.
I wanna just like, start
partying at like 10:00 AM.
Ooh.
- Ooh.
- Nothing but net, slam dunk.
Bingo, pop, pop, pop.
- Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
- Hurry. Hurry. Hurry.
Oh yes, oh yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh I love Vegas.
You know, c'est la vie.
Now, shut up.
(Drew hisses)
(Drew gasps)
(Drew screams)
(Drew growls)
Right out the blowhole.
- Was that your blowhole?
I figured it out.
(Drew laughs)
- Did you do the scorpion?
Did anyone do the scorpion?
Will anyone do the scorpion?
- [Ross] Oh, she's doing it.
What are you doing?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- It is totally delicious.
Oh, there is an after taste.